You know sometimes things just don't work right.
A request might fail for a number of reasons.
Maybe this server is down, maybe the networking is having issues.
Or maybe your request was just simply written poorly.
You know what?
Let's think about that last case an incorrectly written AJAX request.
Head into your script.js file and mess up the Wikipedia string here.
I'll do it by simply typing ASDF over and
over until we don't have a website anymore.
Load up your website and search for you know, an address.
But keep this messed up Wikipedia string here.
Then open up devtools and start poking around.
So for this quiz go ahead and ruin the URL string for the Wikipedia endpoint.
Open up devtools and figure out what related error messages you're seeing.
Specifically, I want to know what is showing up in all caps.
Type your answer in here.